un jour devenu seul raconte innove avec
une avec mais c'est la vie sinon je le
reçois avec une drh
oui direct qui est qui et sur france 2
elle me dit mais vous faites quoi je
suis boulanger à nemours
non elle dira ça marche mais elle
sentait qu'il se passait quelque chose
je sais pas clair et aussi demandé à des
animateurs sur votre chaise non ça
faisait 15 ans que je faisais c'est une
immense chaîne france télévisions c'est
combien de gens travaillent à france
télévisions on attendait iront la moitié
[Rires]
il ya 6 gobelets faut deviner pourquoi
ça a un rapport avec alien à cayenne
excuse moi tu es de la famille designers
ont bien regardé veille à 6 gobelets
s'il vous plaît c'est l'équivalent
normalement de 6 go 8 vers le sig au blé
river
[Applaudissements]
à l'om qui saison des problèmes de
joueurs ils vont ils vont en irak
chercher un joueur il va chercher un
super joueur en irak pays le plan qu à
la commanderie chez eux etc
puis arrive le clasico psg om ils sont
menés 3 0 à la mi temps ils sont entrés
l'irakien le mec qui marquent trois buts
il ya 3 3 à la fin du match maxime style
et téléphone à sa famille fait ouais
tout le monde me connaît maintenant à
paris et vous comment ça va sa femme et
sa mère à lui dit ça se passe pas bien
ton père il vient de d'échapper à un
attentat
ton frère il est à l'hôpital et à soeur
elle s'est fait violer dans une
tournante mais qui dit je suis désolée
je suis vraiment désolé très désolé
c'est toi qu'a voulu qu'on vienne
habiter à marseille le métier qu'ils
voulaient faire petit pilote de char oui
non attention on s'arrête
vous devez attendre qu'il ait dit oui ou
non encore attention parce que la
prochaine fois c'est dehors
merci